こんしゃしゃしゃっしゃじめしゃちょーですs
なにか、こう、、なんかね
なんか最近,,,
nnnnnn
俺もダメなのかな？
脳が、こう、、なんか
下ってきてる気がするんすよ
だって僕..
今僕の趣味を言うとしたら,,,,
やばくないすかw
僕もう25歳だよ～
ｺﾝﾅﾉﾃﾞｲｲﾉｫｫ...って
って思いながら
別にいいやと思ってます
はじめしゃちょーです（泣）
てわけでおもちゃ屋さんに行くと
こんなもの見つけました
ﾊｼﾞﾒﾝ  ＜ドゥドゥン♪
これはいったい何でしょう
これなんだ？
なんかパッと見ね
なんかルービックキューブの
となりとかに置いてあったんで
ともだちかなって思って買ってみたんですけども
なんかそうじゃないみたいでございます
☆ミラーキューブ☆
いろんなかた...
やべ 値段ばれちゃう
780円でしたw （￥＿￥）
ミラーキューブ   いろんな形に変形します
これで変形するって...
ohh ee...eee
だって....
四角ジャン！！
！！！！開けます！！！！
♪開け開け中♪
うわ こわ なにこれ
やばぁ なんか すげえ
で、色はすっごいきれい
ってか普通に家にかざっておきたいレベル
ふつうのルービックキューブだったらこれでこう
ｷｭｼｯ ｷｭｼ ｷｭｼ ｷｭｼｯ
ｷｭｼｷｭｼｷｭｼｯ
ｷｭｰﾌﾞ ＜ ｶｼｬｯ
あ、うごいちゃった
ふつうのルウン...ビンックキューブだったらこう
たてとよこの回転しかできないんですけど
え、もう見るからにね
そういうわけでは  なさそうなんすよね
動かしてみます！！！！
え、もう普通にこれいいの？
うわ まって
ｷｭｰﾌﾞ ＜ ススッ
あっ ふつうのこれは　もうふつうの
ルービックキューブの動きはできますね
ｷｭｰﾌﾞ ＜ カシャッ
ふぇっ　はっはっ はっ！！！
まって  まって...
.......
やばい なんか
すごい形がいびつになっちゃう  これ
こういうやつなのかな...
え、まってこれ取り戻せる？ 俺、自分を...
うわ、すげえ すげえ
パッと見  ふつうのキューブなんですけど
ここだけ「ﾁｮﾝ」って出ちゃってるw
え、なにこれ
形がどんどん変わってっちゃう
これどうすればいいの
もとに戻せば
成功なんでしょうか...
となると僕は多分もう
取り返しのつかないところまで
来てしまっています
----------デｴｴｴｴｴｴｴン------------
助けて（泣）
これもう無理じゃん...
どうやってこれｒ...もどせっていうんだよ
ざけんじゃねぇ
いや もう なんか
どうしようもないことになって来てしまいました
え、まじ どうすればいいのこれ
なんかでも
ルービックキューブと
同じ要素なんですよね　たぶん
ルービックキューブは
色をそろえるんですけども
これはもう
形をそろえる....
ｷｭｰﾌﾞ ＜ カシャッ
おわっとっと
これは形をそろえるというか
たぶん
がんばれば戻せるのではないでしょうか
いや、これやばいな  でも
複雑すぎて
おれの知能だと
一生かかってもできないかもしれないくらいの
やばさを感じるnow
うぅ（泣）
いや、けど多分きっとあれなんだと思います
ルービックキューブの種類のです
どっちが難しいかわかんないすけど...
♪早送り♪
ﾊｼﾞﾒﾝ ＜ ぶるぶるぶるぶるｒ
いやこれ、むずいよ
だってさ
こんなに差つくことあります？
え、これ崩したらおれだって
おわりだぜ多分...
いや、でも面白いっすね
形変わるとやっぱおどろきますね
ふつうこういう形になんないっすもん
うぅぅぅぅ（泣）
えぇぇぇぇえ！！
えぇぇぇぇぇぇえ！！！！
いやもう銀はまだ
なんとか再生できそうなんですけども
再生してえな.....
破片 ＜ ｶﾗｶﾗ
ﾓｰﾓﾔｼﾓｰﾔｰ　ﾓﾔｼﾓｰﾔｰｼﾓﾔｼﾔｰｼ
ﾊｼﾞﾒｼｬｰﾁｮｰ
ﾓﾔﾓﾔﾓﾔﾓﾔ
テテテテン☆